os ajustados são indispensáveis para
fazer máquinas funcionário
e aí como engenheira e apaixonada por
tecnologia essa frase parece que soaria
como música para os meus ouvidos
acontece que eu me encontrei dentro da
engenharia me sentindo totalmente
desajustada ainda que é apaixonada por
tudo que é novo por toda inovação que a
engenharia me permite criar eu senti
aqui aquele de alguma forma não era o
meu lugar
aí eu entendi que na verdade são os
desajustados que criam mundos diferentes
e que a criatividade vem talvez do
desajustamento tarde desajustado em um
local é um processo que pode ser um
pouco doloroso mas a natureza
a semente cresce sozinho no escuro
o diamante precisa de pressão para se
tornar diamante
então talvez essa seja uma parte um
processo da nossa jornada de
transformação
quando eu entendi isso eu percebi que
estava tudo bem não me encaixar
quando a gente não encaixa a gente se
permite transbordar e quando a gente se
permite além
a gente descobre um dos fantásticos mas
aí também a gente percebe que as
respostas que a gente queria
a gente não encontra mais e aí qual é o
segredo para encontrar essas respostas
que a gente quer é fazer melhores
perguntas e foi pensando nisso em quais
seriam as melhores perguntas que eu
poderia fazer o que eu descobri pra mim
a mais importante de todas elas
o que a natureza faria aqui
seja lá o que eu quisesse resolver eu
entendi que se eu mudasse as lentes e as
perspectivas de quem eu estava usando
como mentora para os meus desafios me
traria os resultados que eu estava
querendo e eu descobri a biomimética
biomimética vem do grego bill que é vida
e mimese que a inovação e que a imitação
de uma imitação da vida que permite
criar inovação inspirada pela natureza
novas tecnologias produtos e processos
sistemas tudo isso olhando para a
natureza como modelo medida e mentora
terá natureza como modelo medida e
mentora transformou a minha vida eu digo
que a biomimética aconteceu comigo e
aconteceu pra mim e eu pergunto pra
vocês quem aconteceu pra vocês
a gente tem momentos na vida que são
pontos de mudança extremamente
importantes para mim
a biomédica se tornou de fato a resposta
para o meu propósito
na verdade eu queria trabalhar com
tecnologia e inovação
mas mais do que isso eu não queria
assustar máquinas apenas eu queria
transformar o mundo
então foi na bm médica que eu encontrei
o como eo porquê fazer isso levou a uma
nova perspectiva de mundo se tornou o
maior propósito olhar para a natureza
como a minha grande inspiração
quem aconteceu comigo transformou a
minha forma de pensar
de agir de trabalhar e me relacionar
quando a gente muda o nosso olhar do
mundo a gente transforma todo o nosso
entorno
o impacto é sistêmico
eu me sinto uma pessoa melhor por causa
disso
e aí eu entendi que não importa a
pergunta que eu tivesse a natureza
tinha pensado nesse primeiro
se eu fizer a pergunta certa ela vai ter
resposta para mim aí vocês vão me dizer
ah mas eu perguntar como a natureza cria
um computador
ela não vai me responder é nada
aí eu vou te dizer talvez você esteja
fazendo a pergunta errada e se você
perguntasse como a natureza é comunica
com a natureza envia dados como a
natureza em interpreta sinais entre
tantas outras perguntas possíveis e aí
vocês vão descobrir
milhares de organismos que vão responder
a todas essas perguntas
a partir disso a gente transforma essas
estratégias biológicas em estratégias
industriais em soluções para os nossos
desafios e isso inspira desde a parte de
como nós seres humanos podemos ser
líderes melhores por exemplo até as
novas máquinas que a gente precisa criar
para continuar fazendo mundo que a gente
existe a gente vive hoje
se a gente olhar pra esse é músico que
tinha inocente aí da foto
deixa eu perguntar pra vocês quando
vocês são picados por um deles vocês
sentem alguma coisa na hora da picada
não
depois sim né
agora quando você leva uma injeção
você sente alguma coisa quem gosta de
levar à rejeição de tomar edição ninguém
que bom ninguém é o valor que o
suficiente pra gostar disso né
o que eles estão fazendo é o seguinte
eles estão olhando pra como que funciona
essa troca do mosquito que faz a picada
sertão é sem dor para nós e reproduzir
isso na agulha também aqui do lado a
gente tenha o martim pescador o
trem-bala do japão
ele não podia mais ficar no meio da
cidade porque ele tinha ele causava
poluição sonora
essa poluição sonora era por causa do
ruído de quando ele quebrava a bolha de
área ao sair do túnel
o engenheiro japonês pensou o que na
natureza consegue gerenciar essa quebra
do ar se na água e no ar
os fluídos se comportam praticamente da
mesma forma
eles pensaram vamos ver que organismos
que fazem isso aí eles descobriram o
martim pescador que é extremamente ágil
ele voa vai quebrar a barreira do ar
entra na água estrategicamente
silenciosamente caça presença dele e sai
não espanta os peixes então o que a
gente pode aprender com isso
eles entenderam que a forma que o bico
do martim pescador aerodinâmica do bico
do martim pescador era solução para
fazer o shinkansen que o trem-bala do
japão
o trem não só ficou mais silencioso e
apto a ficar no meio da cidade como
também é reduzir em 15% o consumo e
ficou 10% mais rápida
as melhorias foram muito
além do que somente o ruído que eles
queriam
a natureza é muito inteligente nos
projetos que ela faz
o tubarão quando vocês querem nadar com
quem que a gente vai se inspirar para
nadar melhor
nós seres humanos nadamos naturalmente
nosso ambiente terrestre então a gente
tem que olhar pra quem faz isso direito
o tubarão por exemplo extremamente ágil
mesmo sendo muito pesado e aí uma marca
de esportes olhou pra não há estrutura
da pele do tubarão reproduziu isso numa
roupa de natação e permitiu que os
jogadores pudessem ser mais rápido
porque o atrito da água foi reduzido
além disso a pele do tubarão inspirou um
revestimento de paredes que faz com que
não haja acúmulo e nem reprodução de
bactérias vírus e outras e outros
organismos que podem ser danosos para a
nossa saúde que pode ser usado por
exemplo em hospitais eo companheiro ali
do lado
a gente subestimou né as formigas cupins
além de serem socialmente extremamente
inteligentes e que nos ensinar muito
sobre como viver em sociedade se auto
organizar se autogerir eles também
constroem casas como nenhum engenheiro e
arquiteto jamais pensou a gente tem hoje
um shopping no zimbábue que não tem ar
condicionado porque é porque ele se
inspirou na tubulação de ar dos
cupinzeiros e reproduziu isso nos
shoppings entre então o shopping não
precisa de ar condicionado ele fica numa
temperatura ambiente agradável e os 23
graus
esses são só alguns exemplos que a gente
pode olhar para entender o tanto de
natureza tem de solução para qualquer
desafio que a gente tem
mas a gente só consegue aprender com
aquilo que a gente se relaciona e admira
qual foi a última vez
que vocês estiveram em contato com a
natureza que você se permite olhar com
curiosidade como uma criança faz ao ver
o organismo natural e pergunta nossa
porque é assim porque essa folha do
jeito que é como formiga consegue ter
força para carregar essa folha
equilibrar a ela lembra das perguntas
a gente precisa voltar a ser mais
curiosos
a curiosidade vai nos levar a encontrar
as respostas daquilo que a gente ainda
não está conseguindo enxergar ea
natureza tem resposta para perguntas que
a gente ainda nem pensa em fazer esse
fantástico mas a gente geralmente não
vai admirar quem a gente não se
relaciona o professor que vocês não
gostam vocês vão dizer ah é
não gosto daquela pessoa então você não
vai aprender a matéria você não vai sabe
não vai dar atenção para aquele para
aquilo que você está entendendo
estudando enfim
então pra gente aprender a aprender com
a natureza
a gente precisa voltar a admirá la
voltar a se relacionar com ela e para
isso a gente precisa recolher acta
reconectar com a natureza é reconectar
com nós mesmos porque o que nós somos
natureza
nós somos organismos naturais e o nosso
corpo é fantástico é uma máquina
fantástica
a gente fala máquina né porque a gente
está sempre acostumado a ver de uma
forma mecânica as coisas mas nosso corpo
é um organismo natural com vida e têm
vida dentro da gente
são células são da etérea se tudo está
funcionando e o planeta é um grande
organismo vivo
a gente está inserido pra gente
reconecta a gente precisa voltar a estar
em contato com tudo isso que nos rodeia
com toda essa gente
a unidade que nos rodeia eu vou convidar
vocês para fecharem os olhos e segurar
em uma das mãos de vocês sintam a palma
da mão de vocês como que a palma da mão
de vocês é lisa é áspera
ela é molhada ela tem algum tipo disse
que a atriz aparece com algum tipo de
material ea parte de trás da mão de
vocês como é que é
é igual a palma da mão
agora sim então o mecanismo dos dedos de
vocês é o mesmo mecanismo da palma abre
e fecha com esses dentes
agora sintam a unha de vocês sabiam que
a une um polímero natural
abram os olhos e olhem para a mão de
vocês olhem observe se conecta em olhar
para a mão de vocês foi a mesma coisa
que tocar a mão de vocês provavelmente
não
a gente precisa aprender a olhar de um
lugar novo
somente trocando as nossas lentes é que
a gente consegue encontrar essas
respostas que a gente tanto busca
esse parece loucura tudo bem já estou
acostumada com as pessoas não entenderem
de primeira aquilo que eu faço mas diz
steve jobs que são as pessoas loucas o
suficiente para acreditar que podem
mudar o mundo que vão lá e muda tudo bem
a gente tem um bando de malucos e olhar
para lugares diferentes
não adianta a gente fazer o mesmo sempre
esperar respostas diferentes num mesmo
resultados diferentes
então o que a gente permita lembrar que
seja lá o que a gente tiver pensando a
natureza
pensando nisso o primeiro pra quem vocês
vão começar a fazer perguntas a partir
de agora ligado